all that chit chats gonna get you killed
hey reject nation i'm greg alba
salamander Sally's here with me today I
was like I need a pale white girl if I'm
gonna talk about Harley Quinn and I
found one right on the street guys visit
the corner sound we're gonna watch this
video today from Screen Rant strict
rules Margot Robbie has to play to
follow her there are no take twos that
the real rejects you know what I was
trying to say birds of prey is coming
out soon so I was like this would be fun
to learn I would like to know this
strict rule she has to go through an or
an embodied this character because she
has really embraced Harleen Quinzel she
had a lot of creative control over birds
of prey and de fantabulous emancipation
of Sir Harley Quinn okay let's move row
row row your goats
[Music]
playing an iconic super villain role is
no easy task
yeah we'll see who stole every scene she
appeared in for 2016 Suicide Squad the
actress was fully committed to
performing the park but there were some
pretty strict rules to follow along the
way learn what it was like for Margo on
set how the director forced her into
something on the first day and what it
was like performing with a method actor
like Jared Leto many of these rules and
restrictions transfer oh uh in the
upcoming birds of prey movie as well
what you can do this was definitely the
case for Margot Robbie in Sue's most
beautiful shaved his whole body had
transformed into the Joker there margot
robbie was sourced to go along for the
ride pretty much abiding by the rules
and standards a letter tells you at the
main rules no rehearsals yep no
rehearsals alongside Will Smith and
rehearsing everything else with the rest
of the squad Robbie went blinded to her
scenes with the Joker's so let Owen
director David Ayer could try and
capture the unpredictable nature of the
dysfunctional duo
it went so crazy I think you insane this
means that Margot had to pretty much
switch up her whole preparation and the
way she would approach scenes another
answer she's a profession routine the
randoms gifts he would leave for the
cast along with some adult toys and the
body of a pig
margot robbie got her own personal gift
in the form of a living rack
at least robbie was a good sport about
it actually keeping the road I stopped
at subscribe
was first introduced in Batman the
Animated Series and her voice was one of
the more iconic parts of the show yeah
to get inspiration Robby watched and
listened to several scenes of Harley
Quinn on the Batman animated series one
episode specifically she tuned into the
accent and voice of the character Karen
Hill
Robbie took all of the scenes with Karen
Hill had them converted to audio and
would play them back over and over on
her way to the set the key aspect of
Robbie's delivery was being able to
deliver emotional scenes without getting
too high-pitched or not taken seriously
enough for the role at the end of the
day her unique voice and acting choices
were one of the most praised parts of
the movie that is a hard voicing yeah
when typically wore a full jumpsuit
things would be very different in a live
act we need you to look sexy costume
design was inspired by more mature comic
books rather than the character from an
animated show aimed at children Margot
Robbie was essentially forced to wear
shorts that were so short they would
barely eat oh as are considered shorts
as a new part of the world of comic book
movies Rami did not have authority in
her outfit choice a costume design she
wishes was very different not only did
Robbie have to perform in the
tight-fitting outfit but the actress
often did her own stunts while wearing
the short shorts Oh flashbacks where she
wore different outfits and got to cover
up more but the shorts and t-shirts
although was pretty much a majority of
what she had to wear on second yeah
Filipa Robbie the popularity of her
character led to some pretty pivotal
outfit changes for the upcoming
birds-of-prey movie
Robbie has been seen in trailers hand on
set in longer pants those shorts are
probably never gonna be seen on Robbie
again if she can help
Skinner underneath the Harley Quinn
outfit margot robbie was forced to go
through all types of preparation just to
get her skin ready for the character
harley quinn doesn't seem to get much
Sun money because her pale skin is a
massive difference from other characters
and Luke
Robbie's natural skin was not this Pam
meaning she had to go through a full
body routine in the makeup trailer every
day huh yeah he was so expensive but
just a single scene showing a bare arm
would require the actress to have
another 20 minutes getting her skin
prepared along with her skin getting
around Twinkie temporary tattoos in
total each new day on scent Robbie would
have to have the tattoos applied again
where the makeup artists ensuring they
were in the same exact location to match
up with film Oh in preparation she
needed to have the wig added on along
with the full Harley Quinn outfit the
whole process could take over three
hours sometimes even longer than Jared
Leto's preparation for the Joker the
daily makeup chair wasn't the only
transformation Robbie went through to
get into the role of Harley Quinn on the
very first day of filming director David
Ayer did something drastic when he
approached Robbie and decided to just
shave her eyebrow he took out of my
eyebrow the look could be easily noticed
in the movie and it was just another
quirky part of the character we imagine
Robbie could have easily said no but to
get asked to do that on the very first
day of filming Robbie probably had a lot
of pressure to oblige
and that was gangster the end result
works great for the film and her
eyebrows are fully grown out by now
she was happy to tell the story and it
seems to have no regrets about the
eyebrow is a journey of her carrot he
seems used to introduce Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn was a chase scene involving
Ben Affleck's Batman but their
high-speed chase was not a success the
car plummeted into water and Quinn was
launched through the windshield on the
way down
Batman attempts to rescue Quinn and we
see her trapped underwater for a pretty
long time Farabi
filming the scene required her to go
through extensive breath-holding
training the production set a guideline
for one minute but Robbie pushed her
limits fully training to hold her breath
underwater for a whole five minutes now
that's commitment to the park well I
mean the underwater techniques is no
easy task either Robbie did multiple
weeks of training to learn how to
properly
holding air expand her lungs and to
psychologically handle being in the
water for so long so he always want to
hear about Margot Robbie had to get into
some of the best shape of her life her
goal was to slim down put on a little
muscle and fit into the costume so to
help prepare Robbie focused on a lot of
cardio workouts aside from running the
workout routine also included a lot of
squats and crunches working with a
professional trainer Robbie did full
workout routines to help tone her body
some of the exercises included jump
ropes resistance poles and wearing heavy
ankle weights to help tone ur whole
bottom half
Robbie also found a lot of inspiration
through ballet training she mixed it
dances stretches and a variety of
exercises ballet dancers will commonly
use while they train the workouts began
months before filming and continued
through the production to ensure she
stayed fit and toned throughout the
shoot as production ramped up for birds
of prey Robbie followed the same routine
to help stay in shape to return to her
famous role thankfully the productions
of birds of prey and James Gunn Suicide
Squad were not too far apart so Robbie
just continued down the same path as
before along with the workout routine
Robbie had a pretty strict diet heading
into the suicide of imagines the direct
may have been the hardest part
considering she loves to eat burgers and
fries all the time he came down to get
our only strict of the diet
Robbie munched on a bunch of carrot
sticks this was often her go-to snack
for having a treatment staying healthy
the balance of food Robbie died and
aren't allowed her to sneak in 20 of
cheap meals while filming including the
burger she loved so hard the last thing
she wants to do is skip out on her
favourite food options just to shed a
few pounds or look a specific way for a
role we have to imagine that with a diet
so strict all those lollipops Harley
Quinn has in the movie are most likely
sugar-free otherwise she'd be swapping
out the lollipop for some extra carrot
sticks between takes
security rules for playing a major
character and a big-budget film like
Suicide Squad your life will change
forever
Robbie's transformation into Harley
Quinn came with all kinds of bonuses
she's in two more movies Margot Robbie
has her own action figure there's
posters merch and the character will
live on forever
but so will some of the toxic fans who
make her life a nightmare in the months
following the film's release
Robbie quickly realized the real-life
downfall of starring in a superhero
movie when she began getting threats
from obsessed fans Robbie had to
increase security to get background well
they threatened her about and often have
to pay out of pocket for the extra
support this is one of the biggest
regrets she has going into the wall and
an unwritten rule when it comes to
playing an iconic character like Harley
Quinn despite the negative aspect of
fandom Robbie obviously put on some
positive aspects of the role as well
because she's happily doing multiple
sequels and ready to make harley quinn
all her own once again we imagine the
much larger paycheck will help cover a
lot of the security costs
for the role of Harley Quinn there were
a ton of rules for the specific
character but margot robbie also had to
follow a lot of the general DC EU rules
there have been many rules and rumoured
guidelines about the DC has helped break
a number of these rules before Suicide
Squad one of the main rules was a
no-joke policy based off the joke filled
Green Lantern movie that failed at the
box office as Harley Quinn the Suicide
Squad movie was filled with a ton of
light-hearted moments so we have to say
that the oldc you pretty much went away
with the rumors that real DC if you're
active in the DC EU you can't be popping
up in the MCU and so far another Robbie
has stuck to a DC roots
one of the biggest rules Robbie is
health break is the R rating rule the
first Suicide Squad could have been a
much better movie with an R rating but
things will be very different for birds
of prey when Harley Quinn and company
fly in with an R rating hell yeah birds
of prey could really help bring more
mature comic book movies doing forward
Wow being an actor can be pretty intense
what rule do you think is the most
strict any that we missed is Margot
Robbie the best option for Harley Quinn
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to Screen Rant for more great
DC content I also love the day mentioned
that she used her popularity to keep a
woman director for birds of prey I don't
agree with that choice did you see the
Golden Globe nominations there's a
reason it's all guys women can't direct
I can't think of a single one matter of
fact I can't even think of one woman's
name right now I have a female guest
she'll know I'm messing with her you
know and people still watching Yahoo a
dozen okay well yeah what's up I've seen
interviews with her she's a hardcore
perfectionist like she really likes to
know the full history she does so much
research she does a lot to prepare and
even on the day of shield
a lot of preparation she's a very very
serious actor okay I just say most
actors should do that it's her job and
she's getting paid a lot of money so I
would hope more actors would be more
serious yeah I mean some people love to
be very loose about it some people love
to not really do preparation and just
see what happens in the moment and let
go and some people like to be like her
were later you're a super perfectionist
and then when you do the scene you let
go when you're finally filming some
actors love to rehearse some actors
really don't like rehearsing she strikes
me as the type who would prefer a
rehearsal you know I can imagine that
there was some conflict that she
potentially had when working with Jared
Leto especially since you're supposed to
have this crazy loving toxic
relationship with the Joker that it
could pose a bit of a problem without
being able to create into that history
in between takes or off-camera with that
performer oh yeah she did do a great job
I love what they said about her voice
yeah because Harley Quinn is such a
cartoony character that it is very
difficult to nail down how do you bring
this cartoonish character to life
without it losing realism and she did
that she yeah she did that wonderfully
was that and the idea to get the voice
of Lorraine Bracco that was smart her
dialect was perfect I think for merging
the iconic voice of the voiceovers and
then making it realistic no it's it's
funny hearing all this because now she
has like all this creative control she
produces a lot of movies now she has her
own movie studio the first movie I sorry
I like a lot of people is willful Wall
Street and she's brilliant in that movie
like she's this beautiful actress who's
also extremely talented she's always
he's really skilled I love how much she
doesn't just rely on her looks at all
because she's like a supermodel yeah and
she could be a Meryl Streep down the
road she wants to be you know I Tania
was phenomenal I was just watching the
trailer for the new movie bombshell I'm
like she's great in this movie
she always consistently delivers and it
seems like that there was a lot she had
to say yes to and that I can't tell if
she just had to say yes because you know
she wasn't the superstar that she is now
but now that she has this role and she's
shot to this icon status of being the
first person to bring Harley
life in a really respectable manner big
shoes to fill and she did she filled
those clown shoes man because that whole
thing with the shorts and like that is a
pretty big deal I can imagine that it's
uncomfortable to the action and your art
hyper-sexualized Harley Quinn in this
movie it's rectified dude you know
Harley Quinn's like images have been of
her in a bodysuit I would think that she
was shocked to be like oh I'm literally
wearing underwear yeah I can imagine
that you have to do a lot of saying yes
in the beginning but I think it's pretty
awesome now that she has a lot of
creative control or at least a lot more
creative input
she doesn't have to succumb to any of
these circumstances anymore like the
shaved eyebrow thing I don't get it I
can see how for an actor if you wanted
to do that as a little nugget to help
you out sure I don't think it was
necessary I do know that look
technically is used for people that are
trying to be like gangsters or whatever
so I get maybe why he wanted it but I
don't think that was completely
necessary for her to do yeah I was just
gonna tell the times if she said yes to
things because she felt like she had to
say yes I mean if I had gotten the role
of Harlequin I would have said yes to
everything because it's like you don't
want to jeopardize her breakout role but
it's unfortunate that you can tell she
was probably uncomfortable with certain
things I love that she did like this
breath control training - for such a
brief moment in the film yeah the best
moment when Batman punches a woman
underwater but no it's it's such a short
moment in the film but that's what I
mean by her level of discipline it's so
admirable that she would over a train
that way she can easily do it to come
today oh I love what he said about that
segment it's not only that she just
wanted to have that control it's also
the mental control because when you are
underwater you can panic so I think she
was more of trying to make sure that she
was comfortable being in the water for
that I'm out because when you're on a
set it's already a stressful environment
yeah we always hear about for
superheroes you got to do the diet and
exercise I don't know why I think it's
so hot when I hear
woman loves to throw down with some
nasty-ass food I bet you a minute this
route
she wins like five guys strangely
attractive thing also the whole thing
about the pale skin is something I did
not think about yeah I remember like her
face looks all white and like she's got
the makeup but that's sure they have all
these body shots of her and they have to
make her look like her skin is that
white hey kudos to the makeup by the way
pick up my towel I've heard them having
to do it when people have tattoos and
they have to make them look a little
lighter and they have to literally spray
their whole entire body but it was
interesting because she's Australian
she's like naturally tan yeah I didn't
think about that either I mean it looked
like they definitely packed on the pale
makeup for her face I didn't think about
them having to do it for her body a lot
of times too with these fake tattoos
they usually just put it on the actors
and a lot of the time they just leave it
on their body until productions done but
they can't do that because of the white
makeup so they have to reapply the
tattoo every single day that's very
challenging so weird as this freaking
movie would respect to them for pulling
off the makeup they're much deserved
Oscar nomination I mean I've heard that
like I recently got a tattoo and I was
told oh then you're not gonna get
certain roles I'm like do you realize if
they like you as an actor they'll have
to make it department do whatever they
need to do well guys see Sally's tattoo
check it out you guys see it zoom in
says horny it says honey for all the
directors out there looking for an
actress horny is the name of her tattoo
it's the name of my dog and my dog was
not named horny he was a horny dog
wasn't she was puffy well guys when
Margot Robbie officially retires from
playing Harley Quinn who do you think
should play Harley Quinn you got an
answer Melissa McCarthy why are you
laughing I don't know that's a serious
thing why can't Alyssa McCarthy player
you you know what said anything so
whatever answer you came up with people
already mad
gonna be Ursula for like no reason this
year so I thought clean the teeth over
there anyway hey guys subscribe to
screen rants subscribe for the real
rejects click the notification bell I
have somehow gotten lower than the Sally
in this video check out Sally on YouTube
and Instagram and your on Twitter too
right yeah you always like uh impeach
Trump whatever Trump's made this country
better oh it's funny because the people
who are against Trump know I'm sarcastic
and the people who are for Trump think
I'm since I win both in you loss I want
to end this with a patron of the day
shout out I want to end this with a page
in the day shout out for a woman named
Victoria Huntley now Victoria Huntley
she actually is a major cosplayer her
favorite character Hermione
her favorite movie Kill Bill seen the
bride and she is engaged she will be a
bride simp yeah what oh that's a hurry
giving yeah yeah look out for marriage I
think one day you should cosplay as
Harley Quinn and danger husband could be
mr. J and then to really mix it up he
could be walking Phoenix oh my god that
would be so hot it'd be so sexy that
would be so sexy Victoria don't like do
sexual things just like take photos on
the convention on makeup and be gross by
the time they're done he's gonna be all
covered in white makeup
[Laughter]